Salut.
Je suis sur mon lit là.
Bon, bref.
J'ai eu l'occasion encore dernièrement
de croiser pas mal d'entre vous
et il se trouve que, définitivement,
la question qui revient le plus souvent, c'est :
comment va Cyril ?
Bon, c'est vrai que ça fait longtemps
que je vous ai pas donné de ses nouvelles,
et comme il se trouve que aujourd'hui,
c'est pile le jour de ma troisième séance de laser,
je me suis dit que c'était l'occasion.
Alors, on y va.
Bon, alors avant de commencer,
avant même d'aller à la séance,
ce que je vous propose, c'est de faire un petit point, parce qu'il s'est passé deux mois depuis la dernière fois.
J'ai l'impression
que ça commence gentiment à bouger
Mais, disons que c'est pas encore ça.
Regardez.
Ça, c'est Cyril avant la toute première séance de laser.
En sortie de chez le tatoueur.
Ça, c'est lui après la première séance.
Ça, c'est lui après la deuxième séance.
Et ça c'est Cyril ce matin juste avant de partir.
Mouais, bon alors disons
que ça c'est peut-être un petit peu éclairci,
mais vraiment j'attends mieux.
Et j'espère que ça va être un petit peu plus spectaculaire dans les jours qui viennent
Ah, oui alors petite particularité :
La dernière fois j'avais testé
le détatouage un lendemain de fête.
Petite précision : hier soir j'ai fait la fête.
J'ai un peu abusé des bonnes choses,
faut pas se mentir c'est complètement con,
ne faites pas ça.
Là ce coup là je me suis dit :
tiens, on va tester le laser en pleine canicule.
Comme ça vous aurez un panorama
des situations bien extrêmes.
Voilà, donc là il est sept heures,
il fait déjà bien chaud.
Bon c'est supportable, on va pas se mentir.
J'ai pas beaucoup dormi, à cause de la chaleur,
comme ça peut se voir sur mon faciès
un petit peu défraîchi,
et si je me lève aussi tôt,
c'est parce que avant d'aller à ma séance de laser,
je vais tourner une petite vidéo avec des potes. Voilà.
Petit tournage entre potes à Saint Ouen.
Avant la séance.
Voilà la vidéo est finie, je vais repasser chez moi
pour manger un petit morceau et faire un petit
brin de toilette, parce que bon, on est pas des sagouins
et là on y va.
Alors il fait moins chaud que ces derniers jours,
mais il fait quand même bien chaud.
Allez, c'est parti.
Ça pique un peu.
Oh, j'ai eu chaud.
Ok, dans ce coup-là,
j'ai vraiment pris un vrai vrai coup de chaud,
j'ai fait de la buée sur mes lunettes.
Je vais me poser au calme, souffler un petit peu,
et je vous reparle de tout ça.
Oui donc. Bon, et bah cette fois
le médecin a encore augmenté la puissance
c'est-à-dire encore plus que la deuxième séance
où il avait déjà augmenté la puissance
par rapport à la première.
Autant vous dire que ça a bien,
bien BIEN fait mal,
même si j'ai essayé de rester digne. (pfff)
C'est super.
D'ailleurs, je sais pas pourquoi on fait ça,
pourquoi on dit pas qu'on a mal quand on a mal ?
Comprends pas.
Bref, donc entre la chaleur et la douleur,
je peux vous dire que j'étais vraiment,
VRAIMENT en surchauffe,
genre méga en sueur et tout.
J'ai pas fait de malaise,
mais j'étais pas fier quand même.
Donc, il m'a dit qu'il était à la puissance maximale
pour ce diamètre de laser
et que la prochaine fois,
on changerait de diamètre de laser, du coup.
Autant vous dire que j'ai hâte.
Et donc, le résultat.
C'est ce que vous voulez, bien sûr.
Bon, bah là, c'est ce matin.
Là, c'est le lendemain,
on notera l'apparition de jolies petites cloques.
Et là, c'est le jour d'après.
Ça va un peu mieux,
mais on sent que la chaire a été meurtrie.
Le médecin est confiant...
On va dire que moi aussi, hein.
On n'est qu'à la troisième séance,
il en reste encore trois, on est à mi-chemin.
Gardons la foi.
Maintenant, ce que je vais faire,
c'est que je vais laisser passer l'été
le temps pour tous mes petits macrophages
de bouffer les particules d'encre
explosées par le laser
et on verra à la rentrée.
Du coup, à partir d'aujourd'hui et pour deux mois,
on va se retrouver non pas toutes les semaines,
comme d'habitude,
mais toutes les deux semaines
pour des vidéos spéciales été.
Vous savez, comme l'année dernière en fait.
Bien évidemment,
d'ici là, par pitié,
je vous en supplie !
Mettez-vous bien et surtout...
portez-vous bien.
Bel été.